las altas temperaturas en Chile generan
estragos
los residentes de viña del mar en la
costa central del país limpian los daños
de un gran incendio mientras las llamas
se mantienen vivas y afectan a cientos
de personas y hogares el gobierno
central decretó el estado de catástrofe
en la zona ordenaron subir a todo andaba
buscando una amiga de desaparecía pero
no la puedo encontrar es un caos es un
caos esto una ola de calor que ha
azotado a Chile con temperaturas récord
en algunas zonas y la falta de lluvias
ha intensificado los incendios
forestales que ya han quemado más de
7000 hectáreas en menos de una semana
las autoridades calculan que entre 200 y
500 casas estarían afectadas por las
llamas en Viña del Mar Por lo cual han
desplegado helicópteros y aviones
cisterna además de brigadas terrestres
Bueno tengo tenemos Pérdida total O sea
la familia yo la tengo tan de mi papá
que está más abajo Así que vine a ver
perdimos todo todo se puede decir
documento perdimos vehículo lo que más
siento son unas perrita que se me
quedaron adentro así que están por ahí
están Están muertas afectadas a las
casas de mi suegra la casa de mis amigos
bueno se perdió todo
los bomberos han informado que las
condiciones climáticas actuales podrían
contribuir a que el incendio sea
controlado prontamente